Ladies, when yer man says he’s too sick
to take out the trash, he may not be as lazy!
He might actually have an evolutionary disadvantage.
Hey guys and dolls, Trace here for DNews.
It’s a pretty common trope that a cold or
the flu doesn’t really affect women as much
as it does men.
There’s even kind of a pejorative name for
it, “the man flu”, which implies that
men are just being babies.
Now, of course this is a crazy exaggeration…
being sick sucks for everyone... except…
studies have shown this difference in experience
may have a hint of truth to it.
Empirically, men tend to die more often than
women when they catch tuberculosis, and they’re
five times as likely to get cancer when infected
with HPV.
There are a whole mess of viruses that seem
to be much faster and deadlier in men than
in women, or cause worse outcomes.
Well, a paper, that came out in December of
2016 in the journal Nature Communications
studied a phenomenon where a certain virus
called HTLV-1 caused leukemia to develop and
eventually kill approximately twice as many
Japanese men as Japanese women, but affected
both sexes equally when studied in the Caribbean.
Researchers posited that the biggest explanatory
difference was that in Japan, breastfeeding
goes on for longer than it does in the Caribbean.
Now that may seem unrelated, but think of
it from the virus’ perspective.
Viruses need to spread from host to host to
survive, it doesn’t do them any good to
instantly kill whoever they infect, because
that doesn’t leave enough time for them
to infect others.
Although more research is needed, the authors
of the study suggest that maybe it is evolutionarily
beneficial for a virus to keep women alive
longer, and therefore affect them less severely,
because they’re more likely to pass it onto
their children through breastfeeding.
But, in societies where breastfeeding is less
common, and the risk is lower, the virus has
no such evolutionary imperative.
Another study that came out in 2013 in the
Proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences,
found that when men and women were injected
with the flu vaccine, women showed an increased
antibody response, and more inflammation proteins
in their blood serum, than men did.
Their explanation was that a cluster of genes
which actually make you worse at fighting
viruses are actually increased, or “upregulated”
when your body has higher levels of testosterone.
In fact, men who had high testosterone showed
the lowest antibody response to the vaccine..
The researchers suggest that while this immunosuppressive
response in men does worse when dealing with
viruses, it can actually save lives when it
comes to bacterial infections.
The idea is that men are much more likely
to catch bacterial infections.
Now, those aren’t just dangerous because
they can spread, but because sometimes the
body totally freaks out when it encounters
bacteria, and can lead to a cyclical immune
response called a “cytokine storm”, where
there are just too many immune cells trying
to fight at the same time and they overwhelm
your body, sometimes killing you.
Since men are more prone to these infections,
it makes sense to avoid killing yourself fighting
them.
What we’re trying to say is, both sexes
have a lot to deal with, but men, thanks to
testosterone, seem to suffer a little bit
more when they're sick.
So, show a little compassion, stop calling
it “the man flu”.
It's not just sickness that hits men harder,
it's also breakups.
Check out this video of myself and Amy laying
that out for you.
And please subscribe so you get more DNews.